c'était donc le 10 juin 44 642 personnes
dont 2 400 enfants et des femmes ont été
massacrés puis brûlé par les ss de la
division das reich
plus d'un demi siècle après sans jamais
que l'allemagne exprime un regret ou
demande pardon ce musée de la mémoire a
pris le parti de tout dire tout raconté
christophe devals embrasse françois
privat le centre de la mémoire d'oradour
sur glane l'aboutissement d'une volonté
depuis un demi-siècle dénoncé devant
l'histoire l'horreur d'une guerre ici
tout est mort une ville incendiés
fusillé torturé au lendemain du massacre
le général de gaulle les sites de
conserver en l'état les ruines d'oradour
pour témoigner on tourne les premières
images qui fige dans l'histoire les
vestiges de la barbarie essais ils ont
rassemblé toute la population sur cette
place d'un côté les hommes de l'autre
les femmes et les enfants
les hommes ont les emmener dans des
granges et abattu et puis on a mis le
feu alors cadart
les fans et les enfants on les a
rassemblés dans l'église et on les ia
mitrailler et brûlé vif
cinquante ans plus tard les ruines du
village sont toujours là mais des six
rescapés du massacre il n'en reste que
deux qui peuvent encore témoigner dont
jean d'arc son récit devant la grange où
il aurait dû périr permet de prendre
réellement conscience de l'horreur vécue
par les habitants
fauché par les rafales ss on a entendu
des voix qui parlait qui pleurait qui
t'est plainte
c'est fou de stock à la rouler les
plaques qui pouvaient qu'ils pouvaient
sortir ce que des gens étaient beaucoup
de gens étaient encore you et là il en
musée
aujourd'hui les collégiens qui visitent
les ruines d'auradou reconnaissent les
faits qui s'y sont déroulés mais la
guerre est bien loin de leurs 13 ans ils
ressentent la cruauté qui a dévasté le
village sans réellement pouvoir
comprendre ces morts c'est ça veut rien
dire ça fasse cédé 0 mort un peu c'est
on peut pas tellement exprimer ce qu'on
pense quoi ça fait peur
dans les couloirs du centre de la
mémoire les clés du village marc le
contexte historique expliqué en détail
des photos les témoignages de ceux qui
ont échappé aux ss tous les éléments
nécessaires pour comprendre ce qui s'est
passé à oradour-sur-glane les ruines
sont muettes sur ce qu'il aurait arrivé
ce qui les a fait de venir aux ruines et
donc là avec le nouvel équipement du
sang de la mémoire
nous avons proposé un récit en préalable
à la visite du monument historique le
centre de la mémoire est désormais la
porte des ruines d'oradour mieux que de
ne pas oublier il permettra aux
générations à venir de comprendre